nominations for academy awards are a
little different from the average winner
takes all voting system when academy
members fill out their oscars ballot
they use a voting system that employs
the fairest possible outcome for
nominations and for who wins the oscar
for best picture it's called ranked
choice voting otherwise known as
preferential voting here's how it works
let's imagine we're trying to pick the
best movie snack
we've got popcorn candy chocolate and
soda
each voter will rank the snacks in order
of preference
starting with their favorite followed by
their second third and fourth choice
once all of the first choice votes are
counted
if the snack receives the majority of
the votes it's automatically the winner
if no one gets over 50 percent in a
winner-take-all system candy would still
win but in a ranked choice system the
snack with the fewest votes is
eliminated
so if soda was your first choice your
vote now goes to your second choice
hmm still no winner
let's eliminate the next snack and
redistribute its votes
uh oh
the second place choice on this ballot
was already eliminated
let's take their third choice instead
good thing they completed their full
ballot
this process continues until one snack
reaches 50 percent
yay we have a winner
popcorn the majority has spoken
this is the same voting system used for
nominations voting just on a larger
scale
ultimately 10 best picture nominees are
determined from a pool of eligible films
academy members then rank these 10 films
in order of preference resulting in the
best picture winner
on the ballot academy members list their
favorite film in the first slot followed
by their second third fourth and so on
members are encouraged to include as
many films as possible since listing
only one or two films minimizes the
impact of their vote
once ballads are submitted we have our
oscar winners
enjoy the show
[Applause]
[Music]
you